all right
here we go we
are live i guess july q a
all right a few things i want to start
with a few uh
a few things i want to start with is
that
uh is there anybody in the chat that i
know right now
that i can recognize that i would be
willing to sacrifice themselves
to be moderator i didn't think to plan
this out but
uh brad who is usually our wonderful
moderator
is in south africa right now and uh
and being in south africa our other
moderator is also not
available and so uh and so yeah so if
there's no one this is gonna be pretty
crazy
in the chat um
all right okay so then if it's not gonna
happen we'll just let go crazy there's
someone david marcum who's saying he
wants to be moderated but i'm sorry
david i don't i've never
met you i don't know who you are you
could be the you could be a wonderful
person or just the worst troll
uh that ever lived so you know that's
the difficulty of the stranger
symbolism of the stranger so uh yeah so
we'll do what we can
so if somebody in the chat appears and
uh would like to be moderated that i
know
then i will make you moderator i
see frank growly is there frank would
you be willing to be moderator it's a
little bit of a sacrifice
but if not then we'll just go and and uh
and we'll let the chaos roll
so uh
all right so here we go uh and so i
wanted to
start out by saying that
there has been a serious problem oh
lisa is there alisa you're so kind she's
there to
to to moderate i know it's like super
late for you guys
i appreciate i appreciate the sacrifice
and i
wait frank says he wants to be a
moderator so
let me make frank moderator um
how do i do this there you go all right
frank you are you are
you are officially moderate i trust i
trust frank lisa so
if you need to go if you need to go to
sleep uh if you're doing something else
then go ahead because i i definitely uh
trust frank
all right so thanks frank
okay uh so let's go so there has been
some of you might have noticed some of
you might have not noticed we've been
having serious problems with
the website and i'm not totally sure
what exactly is going on with the uh
with the website i've been
in discussion with the people who are
managing it in terms of uh technical
stuff
and they don't totally seem to know
what's going on either yet
uh and so what that means is that
uh some of people like i know some
people
have been kind of uh cut out of the
website like some people that have been
supporting me or have been subscribed to
the website
can't access the content some people
that have been supporting me are being
their supporters being cancelled
automatically and i don't know why
uh maybe some people are are canceling
on purpose but some people i know have
been cut out because they've written me
and said
like what's going on it says that my
payments is going through or that my
subscription is canceled so so uh sorry
about that i don't know what to say
all i know is that i put in the chat the
email
um for mark ramer
uh he is the person who is running the
who's
running the technical part of the
website so look in the chat it's not
very far
you can find his email and you can email
him
uh to tell him that it's not working and
he will he will
fix the problem he's been able to uh
he's been able to fix the problem
individually for people but we haven't
totally found like let's say the big
problem like what exactly is doing this
if it's a plug-in
who knows i don't know i'm not a
technical person so uh so yeah so sorry
about that for those who have been
uh suffering that it's really from the
website those who are supporting me
through patreon
seem to uh seem to be seem to be going
fine so um
so all right all right so
i i as i look at the questions i'm
realizing like
this is just becoming so completely
unimaginable
unmanageable there there's like 75
questions or like 80 questions so
look i'm just gonna go through and i'm
gonna start and uh
when i totally run out of steam i'm just
gonna have to stop and so
so uh so sorry for those that i if i
don't get your question i
apologize for that and uh yeah and so
we'll do what we can
so thanks to everybody for your support
though i really appreciate it
and sorry that you're trying to support
me and it's so complicated
i really appreciate it uh you know it's
it's uh it's uh
it's very touching that you uh that
you're willing to to support me and to
do this so
all right so let's go
i will start with the uh with the
website even though
it is not it is it is diff i know that
not everybody who wanted to ask a
question was maybe able to but uh
there's already so many questions
anyways
um is there other announcements yes the
other announcement is as
many some of you might oh brad is there
brad is in the chat you guys are so
awesome
you guys are just the best friend lisa
thank you for for coming
even though it's like it's like in the
in the middle of the night for you guys
i appreciate it
um okay so
um all right so here we go we're gonna
do what we can
i wouldn't know what i wanted to say is
i uh next week i am going to be
in denmark for uh the manifesto
uh which is it european men's gathering
it's going to be very intense
because it is really like uh it's going
to be like kind of diving into the fire
at least for me because
the all kinds of people there all kinds
of different thinkers different opinions
you know uh everything from kind of uh
kind of more new age
thinking to atheists to kind of
nietzschean
thinkers uh all kinds of stuff and so so
for me to really be a great i think
it'll be a great uh experience
to kind of to see you know to what
extent i can speak into that world but
it's a pretty it's it's a pretty
exciting uh
group i you know i enjoy their their
energy and their their willingness to
for all the things they're willing
they're going to do there will be an
orthodox streets there as well which is
one of the things that is is making me
want to participate
um and so all right so let's go so i'm
hoping to see some of you there
uh it's like a three-day thing and uh
and
and i'm i'm will i'm hoping that i can
meet some of you uh some of you there
that'd be great
it'd be nice to travel i've been
traveled since the beginning of kovid
and uh you know get a feeling like it's
this
is a very small window to uh to travel
in and that this window is gonna shut
down
pretty soon if you see what's going on
like in australia and places like that
and uh you know these new shutdowns and
these variants and you know the
infinite variants that are popping up
and uh
yeah all right so and the po the kovid
passport which is coming here in quebec
is also going to be a little bit of an
issue
let's say as we watch these measures
kind of take
take root another thing that should
happen and i'm hoping will happen is
that
i'm supposed to be speaking in october
at the uh
the oca the orthodox church of america's
diocese of the south annual their die
season meeting
uh that's where the last time i spoke
there uh
as the keynote speaker that's where i i
put together the
pentecost of the zombie apocalypse talk
and so uh so i'm excited to go there
again to speak there
i'm a little worried because that talk
was like it was so intense for me like
there was so much that i put in there uh
i'm i'm thinking can i pull it off again
something that is as uh you know that
it's as composed and as relevant so i'm
a little nervous about that but all
also excited at the same time so those
are the things that are happening last
thing that's going
coming again another travel i need to
put these all on the website on my
calendar
is i'm going to be in chicago probably
i'm going to speak in chicago also in
october
at the catholic arts guild uh they're
having a conference there
i'll be posting the details of that very
soon but
if you're so if you're in the area of
chicago in uh kind of
try to keep that on your horizon that in
october i will be there speaking at a
conference
um and spending a few days there in
chicago so all right so that is
enough uh announcements for now
things have been kind of slower a little
bit in the summer i've been taking i
took a few weeks vacation which is
really nice with my family
but um yeah i'm ready to dive back in so
here we go
so uh first question from the website
david flores
says what is the relationship between
time and truth
it seems like in the current breakdown
many revelations concerning corruption
and illicit actions in media and
politics are coming to light as
revelation part of fragmentation
and he says i'm also having login issues
through symbolic world yeah david i
man i'm gonna see this is gonna this is
gonna be a theme i think in this q a
so um yes there there is a there's a
mystery
there's definitely a mystery and you can
see it in some of the words that christ
talks about there's something i think i
mentioned this before which is that
christ seems to have been speaking of
what he was bringing about let's say the
kingdom that he was bringing about was
one which
was going to lead toward the end of
things
it would lead towards the the great
judgment okay and
in that movement it's like a movement of
revelation
and so you can understand it as like
kind of christ filling up the world but
the way he fills up the world
is not necessarily the way that we might
expect it just like people didn't expect
the messiah
to come in the way that he did it seems
to be
part of it seems to be through scandal
as well that is
that everything is being revealed and so
some of the things that are being
revealed are also the dark sides of
things and the
corruption the the the scandals that
christ said
must happen are also being revealed and
that seems to be part of what christ
is doing let's say cosmically
is is revealing everything and but that
part of that means also
it doesn't excuse all the insanity that
we're seeing all the corruption
all the this kind of degeneracy that is
coming up you know
uh just this kind of moral chaos and
um you know and the the tyrannical
aspects of power all of these things are
kind of being revealed
in in this moment and like i said it
doesn't justify them but it seems to be
part of what the work
of christ is um
and so you know i've even gone as far
and this is going to maybe scandalize
some people but i think that even the
kind of
this kind of uh
like this pornography making culture
like this culture that has become
pornographic
uh seems to be uh let's say an effect of
christ in the world that is
every single dark thing is
coming to light every single perversion
every single
uh you know every single dark aspect of
what humans are capable of is is
is becoming visible and so and so
you can imagine it really like this idea
that christ talks about gathering the
wheat and the
snares together in the end and then the
judgment comes when
all of it is revealed when everything is
revealed uh and so until then
things continue to to to to appear and
so you imagine it usually we think about
it like
the revelation of the saints you hear
people say things like you know that
that uh you know the the the world will
continue
until all the saints are revealed let's
say and i think that's true but i think
there's also a darker side to that which
is the world
is also revealing all all of its all the
scum is also coming to light you know so
imagine it's
it's really like you know the light
coming down the mountain all the way
down
into the lower waters and revealing
everything and some of that stuff isn't
uh
isn't pretty um
all right so mj villa
mj villain look at these people you guys
are wonderful you're actually solving
the issue
he says for for those having login
issues when i eventually noticed the box
at the bottom
of the screen asking me to accept
cookies and i did so
i was finally logged in before it was an
infinite loop of logging in and being
told i needed to log in to view patreon
content so maybe that's what's happening
i don't know i can't
know that right now but maybe that's the
pro that maybe that's the solution and
i'm sorry if that if
that's it well if that's it then that's
an easy solution to the problem
um
uh my question is what is the symbol of
the honeydew list
uh is there an expression of such a
thing in french does it
have both a positive and negative aspect
there must not be such an expression in
french because i have no idea what that
is
what's a honeydew list
is it like a meme i don't know you guys
you guys are you guys are just
uh exposing my boomer my boomer status
here
honeydew list
oh is this like something that oh is it
like the idea of a wife who
uh a wife who posts uh problems in the
house and then asks her husband to do it
um yeah i think that that's what it
looks like all right so if that's what
it is if that's my understanding
uh then what's the symbolism of it i
mean i've talked about this before
which is you know obviously we need to
be careful when i talk about masculine
feminine obviously
these exist at every level of reality
and so a person also has a
masculine feminine aspect in them but
let's say
nonetheless women usually manifest more
the feminine let's say in the world and
so the idea that i've talked about is
how
one of the aspects of the feminine is to
pose the question is to frame the
problem or to
or to create the frame in which an
answer must be given and so
just like the mother of god comes to
christ and poses the problem you can
imagine
like this is horrible that i'm i'm
seeing it this way but like you know the
mother of god comes to christ and gives
him
his her to her to do list she says
there's a problem with the wine there's
not enough wine what are you going to do
about it uh and and that's it like
that's this framing of the problem and
then
the masculine will then come and give
the give the answer let's say to that
question or to that problem uh so that's
so that's why that's why i see it
unless i misunderstand what it is but
that seems to be what it is all right so
c s stritzel asks what is the symbolism
of miscarriage
and so this is a really important uh
symbolism um
there are several aspects to it but we
if we think about the miscarriage as
a a the the
the the child that doesn't reach life
you know and the idea of a of aborted
fetus or a fetus that
doesn't come to life uh there's a very
rich symbolism
related to that and it has to do with
the idea of something which is not fully
formed
and so there's a reason also why uh
you know let's say the unborn fetus
appears to us uh in a monstrous
way it is it is ill-formed
and so there's a relationship between
like in this in scripture the word
sometimes the word that talks about the
idea of
fallenness or the fallen this idea of
angels falling or this
type of language about about these
things that fall they are related to
miscarriages
they are related to to beings that are
that aren't completely formed or that
that don't that haven't connected heaven
and earth together
so you can imagine the giants for
example
as a kind of cosmic miscarriage you know
as these
not fully not properly formed beings
that exist on the margin
of reality um
and so uh and so that's really the uh
that's really the symbolism of uh
of miscarriage it has to do with the
fall for sure you can understand how
you know that miscarriage is a
consequence of the fall
because it is the improper or the the
the miss of heaven and earth right the
the midst of the of how these things
come together and
and then manifest the living being um
and so it's also there's also a
relationship
direct relationship between monstrosity
and miscarriage
in a more explicit way which is that
often the
the children often uh babies that
were born dead let's say that that are
born without life
uh the visual aspect that we have of
monsters
uh will come from that and so you've
probably seen
some some of these uh let's say deformed
uh
children have been kept you can find
images of them and
that they've been preserved and
sometimes you know they'll they'll have
all the deformities that we recognize
as monstrous like uh just one eye in the
middle or
you know feet that look like animals or
you know
uh like legs that look like uh like uh
like serpents or you know this
that the way that we kind of project our
imagination into these ill-formed uh
humans ends up being
part of what feeds our vision of the
cosmic
miscarriage or the these cosmic monsters
that exist
on the uh on the outside of reality you
know the gog and magog that are kind of
held out of the world by the you know by
the gates of alexander that type of
stuff and
you'll also see that often there's a
relationship even between monsters and
the eating of aborted
babies you know we talked about this uh
richard rowland brought it up slightly
in uh our discussion about the
apocalypse of pseudomethodius
but there's this whole this whole
tradition of these monstrous creatures
on the edge of the world that one of the
things they do is they eat they eat
uh aborted fetuses and uh and so this
relationship between
that is their food like this this
unformed being this like
not totally formed beings are there are
their food
all right all right so people in the que
you guys are awesome in the comment
section someone says you should need to
email matthew raymer
and so it's like he dealt with it so yes
please email matthew raymer if you can't
get into the website
uh or try the trick that that uh that
was mentioned earlier
um so samuel asks how
what something's going on
i was literally okay this is insane i
was literally
i was literally right now
just cut out of the website like i was
literally logged out i have to kind of
relog
into the website what an insane world
this is
all right i don't know what's going on
here all right okay
we're back we're back all right sorry
all right uh so samuel asks what how can
we see the difference between spiritual
development and pre-list
petersburg the potential vision of
christ when he noticed himself feeling
honored to see him
whereas saint paul on the road to
damascus falls down automatically before
christ without knowing
even who he is what role does the
submitter
have to play in these kind of situation
it's part of a vision's inside falseness
how we receive it
well definitely this is a kind of
universal thing and and you'll read
in the the hesticastic fathers which is
that you know
just like saint paiseo said that if if a
vision or a spiritual experience causes
you to have pride
and to lord it over others then it's
already
problematic it's already a problem um
and so definitely this is one of the
reasons this kind of
stuff is one of the reasons why in the
church spiritually you're supposed to
have some kind of a spiritual father you
have someone that you are
supposed to help you discern
and uh and that's that's part of the
that's part of how you can
tell the difference is by sharing it
into the church so that you know the the
person who has direct authority over you
can help you uh judge and it's not just
like
it's not just about following rules and
following it's also because
the your spiritual father or your
confessor or the or a priest
will say things to you and and as and
we'll
we'll prod you and we'll ask questions
and we'll try to see
what's going on and you can also judge
in yourself how you react to that
if you get offended if you're annoyed if
you if you feel like your pride is being
bothered then already you can have a
sense of what's going on
so it's not just about just like the
authority kind of deciding it's about
this interaction with authority which is
also showing you what your attitude
is in your spiritual development um so
yeah so
mark uh greetings from tbilisi georgia
i'm
new here and enjoying this exploration
of the space while learning this new
language
assuming covet is a hybrid a mixture of
different viruses
how does this fit in in our your
symbolic world view
uh i mean let's say that's what it is
especially in
in the theory that it was made in a lab
then it fits very well
with our worldview doesn't it right the
idea
of of of these of this desire to create
these hybrid
creatures and that how these hybrid
creatures
are unleashed on us willingly or
unwillingly
uh and cause uh a kind of chaos
and so you know if kobe is a
is also a kind of man-made hybrid then
it
totally participates in the uh
let's say in the narrative of hybridity
which is assaulting us more and more i
mean i'm sure you guys have seen
people have been tweeting at feeding
this at me for a while
the the uh the whole this new movie by
uh 824
about this hybrid lamb child i forget
what it's called i think it's called
just the lamp or something
you know you're going to see a lot more
of this you're going to see so much of
it you have no idea
you know at least it's a horror movie uh
which
which uh which is this is
like a24 has had some interesting things
like i ended up ended up finally did
watch uh
what's he called mid-summer which people
everybody was telling me watch
mid-summer mid-summer and and uh
the fact that it was framed as a horror
movie this kind of rise of paganism i
thought and this
this return to kind of scapegoat
mechanism and everything
um i thought was appropriate actually
for what what it is and what's going on
in this return to
to to uh to a scapegoat mechanism and
the return to psychedelics too it's like
i was surprising
uh how how it was presented in uh
in mid-summer so
so worm hatcher asks hi jonathan i spent
many years involving cartooning
specifically in drawing comics
that had a kind of 90 subversive ethic
since coming into the church and
observing creation
from a different expanded vantage point
i've not been able to engage with that
kind of creativity as i used to
i still have impulsive desires to create
in that mode it feels unresolved
i got a sense that i need to understand
it slower quality before i could
possibly recap
recapitulate it is there a right or good
use of this kind of energy
what is the symbolism of cartooning
thank you and so
i think that cartooning is actually a
very appropriate
mode of expression and it in terms of
of course there are different uses for
it but i think it can be very powerful
for someone who wields it well because
it is
like icons right it is an image with
text just like comic books in general
and so it has a great potential
to to kind of reach heights that uh
people might not
totally understand and the fact that
cartooning or cartoons and
comic books and all of this is seen as a
very low art form as a kind of popular
almost trashy art form is even better
it's even better in terms of uh
the surprise that it can bring you know
in uh
there's a reason why scripture was
written in uh in kind of popular greek
in koine and there's uh there's a reason
also why
dante wrote in uh in italian rather than
latin
because there's a relationship between
the highest thing kind of hiding in the
lowest place let's say
uh you know this is something christ
talks about in terms of the fish and
this that type of symbolism
and even just the whole aesthetic of of
the idea of
uh of the poor and how christ manifests
himself in the littlest of these
and so this can be this is not just a
moral question but it's an ontological
question you know it's like the waters
below sometimes can reflect that which
is above
sometimes it's trash like you say most
of cartooning in comic books is trash
but it has it has a possibility
and so i would say not to give up on
that like not not to give that up
to uh to to to continue to try to
explore
how it is that you can that you can
create
visual images with text that
uh that can speak to higher things um
but there's also a place for
um for social criticism which some of
the some cartoons can also do
kind of caricature all of that i think
has a purpose
in uh kind of uh in terms in terms of
the the full aesthetic the whole holy
full
idea of you know how the the holy fool
is also there to poke at the system
and so i think all of that is is totally
appropriate
um all right
all right so so christian
asks what is the difference between the
hybrid and the character of the margins
and so they aren't different the hybrid
is a character of the margin
there are different characters in the
margin but the hybrid is one of the
characters of the margin
so you always have to be careful you
always have to remember like when i talk
about things
i i talk about them in in an ontological
way
and so in their place in the cosmic
let's say pattern
that there is nothing wrong with hybrids
per se
the hybrids are a necessary
characteristic of
they're kind of a necessary
characteristic of the fallen world let's
say but not just
but but there's something mysterious
about them which means that they also
act as guardians of identities which is
why we have hybrids
that's why cherubs are represented as
hybrids why we have uh
sphinx type characters that guard holy
places so
and you have gargoyles on the outside of
churches the this
this kind of liminal space between
identities has a function
and it has a it has a sacred function
and so
you have to be careful when i talk about
hybrids and
and the fact that i talk about let's say
now the assault of hybrids
uh it's it's it shows you where you are
in the pattern right but there is there
is a holy hybrid right that's why
i love saint christopher so much and so
it's not it's so it's not about seeing
that all hybridity is bad or that all
hybridity is good
you know there definitely is a um
a problem right now which is this kind
of this
story of hybridity as let's say kind of
seeping in and taking over the narrative
and also
the hybrid being represented as the
central character
as the as a you know as the savior let's
say
this is the problem you know but the the
fact of hybrids is not a problem in the
in itself
um so hope that makes sense um
um okay so david marcum so there's david
markham i saw you in the chat before so
here's a question from david mark
markham um
it's not a question though so maybe i
should skip it and see
all right i'm going to skip it because
it's not a question sorry david you need
to ask questions in this i'll read your
comment but but you need to
to ask questions all right so so
uh shay shay or say mckenna asks
hey jonathan i'm struggling to find a
church to get involved in i honestly
don't even know what denomination i
subscribe to anymore
i feel i'm stuck and i end up not going
to any at all any advice for a step
toward grounding um i mean i i'm sorry
i'm sorry
i know that's a struggle it's a struggle
because we we're in a time when
when uh when christianity is somewhat
dilapidated and so it's difficult to
find and so
this is this is my advice to you is
definitely to
to look towards liturgical to liturgical
church
you know obviously i think orthodoxy has
the most
of that but there are other you know the
catholic church is
is somewhat literal traditional
catholicism especially
um and if you can't even find that let's
say you know there are some anglican
churches that are still
uh somewhat liturgical uh the reason why
i'm saying that is because
one of the problems with churches or the
problem with churches that are very
informal is that everything rests on
the pastor or everything rests on what
is being said at the pulpit
and so you're you sometimes you get
stuck because like if you have a good
pastor then you want to go to church
you have a bad pastor then you don't
want to go to church but if you find a
liturgical
church then even if the pastor says
crazy things or is not
amazing or is is off then
the the liturgy itself can carry you
because it has its own
power it's a witness to it to an entire
tradition of people who who who brought
it together and recognize it as
manifesting the pattern of
of worship and the pattern of christ and
so that's what i would suggest
you know but i i suffer with you i
understand that that's difficult
um
so all right so kelly madden says what
is the meaning of the number five
specifically the story of david and
goliath specified that david took
five smooth stones from the brook for
his sling
when he went out to face the giant but
he only used one
and so obviously the the symbolism of
five is multiple
but to me at least the best way to
understand the symbolism of five i've
talked about this in the
i did a video on the symbolism of the
pentagram um
i think it was i think it was a
subscriber only video though sorry
uh it's four plus one is the best way to
understand
five in my opinion so it's like so it's
like four corners and a center
and so like a pyramid with four corners
and a center or
kind of like a pentagram with four
corners and a and a top
like the head and the four arms so you
can imagine it's something like
he took five stones like this the the
two arms and the two legs
and the head and he took the stone for
the head is the one that hit
goliath in the head and knocked him out
uh you know so there's an analogy
between
between let's say the human person and
the fifth stone
which is the one which which it's funny
enough because it's like that let's say
the top head it hits them in the
in the forehead so it's like uh it's
like you can understand that that's
what a giant is lacking in
spirit let's say too much body and so
it's like by by taking
the stone which is like the head and
then hitting him in the forehead
uh that's how you knock him out right a
seed a seed to the forehead
makes the giant cease to exist giving
meaning to
to chaos is what makes the giant cease
to exist so anyways that's one
interpretation
that's probably the best way at least
that's the way i tend to understand five
almost always as as that four and one
all right josh the mover says why is
there such an emphasis on repentance
right before death even if the proper
christian has regularly repented
and descended in virtues all his life
long if god stands outside of time what
makes the span of time
between repentance and death so
important
so this is going to be so for example in
in the orthodox tradition there there
there are different strains let's say
but one of the strains is that
there is no repentance after death um
and it's like i'm not so sure about
about all of that like i'm not so sure
about all that but
the idea is that the the your your what
happens after death
your life is now and and and
this is this is what will this is the
body which will
let's say inform what what is after
death
um and so i think that's why repentance
before death has become so important
because there's a sense in which uh
you know you kind of have to consume
everything right you
you know the way you die has import
in in your eternal self or your immortal
self you know which is why martyrdom is
important
you know uh and so it reveals something
about you so how about that
like the way something ends reveals a
great deal about that being
because the end of something is its
finality
and it it's like it's the final fruits
of that of that person
um and so you can understand it that way
and so the idea is
you would want to repent before you die
uh so that you know
the idea is that you end in
in christ that your ending is good
um but i but obviously i don't think
that if you don't if you know for
something happens to you and you don't
you're not you die in a car crash or
something you're not able to repent
before you die i
i would i would struggle to see that as
an absolute thing i'd rather
i'd rather see it more liturgically as
this kind of participation
we all kind of go through um
this kind of uh this poetic
participation you could say
so fred c says could you can you explain
the symbol symbolic relation between
head and the heart
in the head body symbolism the head
represents the highest point and center
but in plenty of mystical writings the
heart
is also considered the highest point and
center of the person
and so that's probably that's probably
you kind of
you grasp at it in your text which is
that
it's not a it there's um how can i say
this
it's like it's a it's a polyvalent
symbolism
so sometimes this that which will
represent
the head is the same thing which will
represent the heart
like the center and if you understand it
in a hierarchy
um and so you can understand that in the
sense of when we talk about christ as
the head of the body
you know it's similar to the heart but
not completely
and so if you want to understand the
difference between the head and the
heart for example
is an image to look at would be an image
of the ascension
so and or an image of a church so you
can imagine
let's say you look at a church and you
have an arch
right let's say the apps of the church
if you if you look at as a cut section
it's like an arch so you have heaven
above and then you have the square the
earth below
and then in the middle you have the
altar and you have the place where
heaven and earth meet so you can
understand that so in that sense
that's when if there's a difference
between the head and the heart that's
how you need to understand it
that is the head is something like
heaven the body is something like earth
and the heart is the place in which that
the let's say the abstract or let's say
abstracts maybe not the the invisible
patterns
meet with the body and then create this
unity of action
um so that's the best way i think
to understand that so again like i said
so the church heaven above
earth below and then a meeting place the
tabernacle in the middle
something like that
but it's it's tricky because the
symbolism of the head can sometimes be
the same as the symbolism of the heart
uh it just depends on how symbolism
is also it also it always also depends
at how granular you go
in terms of the symbolism and so
yeah so if you if you have an image of
the head and body then the head is
closer to the image of the heart in the
sense that it's the seed you know it's
the the point
it's all of that like a pyramid but if
you have a relationship between
let's say like if you see in the image
of the nativity for example
you have an image of the the pattern the
mountain
of god and then you have the glory of
god above
and then there's like a cave in the
middle and then there's the incarnation
in the center
and so in that sense it then becomes
like the secret place in the middle
where where heaven and earth meet all
right so hopefully that's
helpful all right so
dumash asked what is the symbolism
of the prohibition against boiling a kid
in his mother's milk on one level it's
taking something it's supposed to be
nurturing
but then using it for death but but it
might also be related to wisdom
uh like when paul talks about the
corinthians only being able to drink
milk rather than eat meat
in my my estimation this has more to do
with a with a confusion of causality
it's something like uh like incest where
you it's related to what you said like
it
and so you you you actually the like you
said like the thing that nurtures the
child
becomes it's the the thing that you
you're going to eat it in a confused
way so it's like you have something that
is the the milk of the mother
and then that which eats the milk and
then you put them together in a confused
manner and then you
you end up eating it so i think it has
more to do with that and more to do with
confusion of causality
like you know that's the way that i
understand that
um yeah and so you can see it like if
you look at jewish kosher law you can
kind of understand
you can understand it a little more
because for them it's all about keeping
things separate
it's all about you know they they push
this very far but you can
you can still help you understand what
it's about you know it's like they
completely separate
the milk and the meat and so it's like
it's it's a different levels of reality
that you have to keep separate and that
you don't want to
you don't want to mix together or else
it uh it creates confusion
um but i think that
when saint paul talks about the
difference between drinking milk and
eating meat it has something to do with
that maybe not exactly
but it has something to do with showing
you two different levels of ontological
reality one higher one lower
and you don't want to confuse them right
that's how you make giants and you
confuse them when they're not joined
properly together
um yeah like in an opposite way the way
that
you're supposed to be joined together
because you do end up let's say eating
the milk of the mother
because the child will drink the milk
that's the way you're supposed to
consume that properly but now it's like
a
like a weird confusion of categories all
right i need to go faster through these
or else i'll never make it
um all right so
all right so kingsley asks when
evangelicals stress the importance of
sharing the gospel
this off again gets condensed down to
god is good and loving
our sin separated from god so christ
died and resurrected to united us so
receive christ through faith
can a simplified gospel message ever be
helpful to share or is it more often
than not a form of propaganda that
diminishes the christian story
um
uh i mean i think that it's fine
like it's fine to to say those things
because
they're not completely false um
i think the problem with the way that
it's presented
today it's like this weird formula right
this like weird formula
that's like here's something like here's
your state if you do this
if you believe this then you're you're
saved
and that's definitely not the gospel
like that's definitely not the gospel
you know it the gospel is not about
about how to get saved in that sense uh
it's really about you know about the
the good news is christ like the good
news is the incarnation of god in the
world
and the transformation that that brings
the revelation of the true nature of
reality
and how we can participate in that uh
and how that brings us up into god
uh but but uh yeah so i i i'm not a big
fan of the
of that kind of reductive thing which is
why you'll probably never hear me say
something
like that um although like i said i'm
not saying that that it's not uh
this it's not completely false like it's
not completely false
all right so
all right so we're done with the website
and there are far fewer questions on the
website probably because nobody could
log into the website so man of life
all right so sorry about that i will
stop apologizing about that because
it's gonna get annoying okay so let's
let me just load all the comments
on patreon so let's go to patreon or
we're looking at like 40
40 something questions on patreon um
all right so our murray says uh please
comment on the symbolism of
homeschooling both historically and in
today's society
um so we homeschooled like not
our kids are in school now mostly
because of the flood that happened in
our house and because of
of covid um strangely enough you'd think
maybe the opposite but
i think that the the the desire to
homeschool now
is the witness to the corruption of the
system mostly
it's mostly because people notice that
the system has become
ideological that the system
has you know is making factory children
that the system
is confusing wisdom and um
and and just uh information
all of that is what i think at least in
my case
brings the desire to homeschool your
children
um it it doesn't it's it has it's it's
not com
it's not completely positive like it's a
sign
that society isn't doing super well uh
when you feel like you have to
homeschool but you also should if
if you're noticing that you know the the
school system in which your your
children are gonna go it's gonna it's
completely corrupt and completely
immoral
then then i think homeschooling is
definitely uh a thing to do
but there is a manner in which
homeschooling can also be
a a kind of refusing to participate in
society but sometimes you have to do
that you know
you have to do that when society is
completely corrupt but but um
but you have to balance it out you know
it's like to be honest like if i
if i lived in a place where i had a good
access to
a school that i could trust you know
with teachers that
were you know were were
christian or at least had sound thinking
classical thinking classical values
then i probably i don't think we would
have homeschooled but
um but that was not the case
um so gr asked hi jonathan hope this is
not too long i wanted to ask if evil
could be understood as the contour
reality
or of god's extension therefore being
being like a fractal mandelbrot set
which is infinite while also being
differentiated from a non-intelligible
outside
this would make evil non-existence
necessary to define good
hell being the fractal on the margin
eternally infinitely dispersed towards
nothingness thank you
so i think that no i don't think i don't
think that's the best way to understand
it
because evil is present at
every step of the hierarchy
of being in when that aspect of reality
uh how can i say this when that aspect
of reality ignores
where it's from when that aspect of
reality sees itself as all-encompassing
or as have value in itself
and so that's to me when something like
evil appears
um and so you so pride for example
is it is a is the first evil but it's an
evil which is
is like at the top of the hierarchy you
know it's like when you as you ascend
the hierarchy you get closer to
something which could become pride
and uh and then that is actually what
can cause you to fall
and so you you see it if you look at the
image of the ladder of divine ascent for
example you see a good example of that
which is that
everywhere on the on the ladder of
divine ascent you can fall and there's
even
a a very good tradition which is
that not only can you fall but the
higher you go the more
the more you fall like the higher you go
the more in danger you are
to fall in a way that could lose you for
a longer time
and so that so the monk who falls
into prayerless then goes up the
mountain and then becomes full of
himself
that monk is in more spiritual danger
than
you know the the the prostitute who who
feels bad about what he's doing and and
and and wants to change and
and you know is asking for forgiveness
you know that's the reality
you know and it's a it's a tough one but
it's some it's one which we see
in the things christ says all the time
you know it's like the
the pharisees are in far more danger uh
spiritually
than the tax collectors and the
prostitutes
so all right
so ron wood says our secular space is
even a possibility
it seems as if where i am now that there
are mainly a buffer space between the
lens of christianity
and the lens of modernity yeah good call
i understand that narthex is a secular
space of sorts but of course even
it is a symbolically significant buffer
within the symbolic language its
secularity
in the common tongue and as tom holland
uses it a concept of modern post-modern
area christianity
the earth is the lords and fullness
thereof yes i totally agree with you
i think the way to understand it is to
understand it fractally as usual
right as like you said so you can
understand that
the church is has a special microcosmic
function
like as an anchor of reality and so it
has everything in it
and it also has the breakdown and the
the hybridity on the edge
but then that represents then that
manifests itself
in a social level as well and so in the
social in the secular space or in the
the space uh the political space or the
social space
then that reality is is there as well
and so every
every aspect of life can become sacred
every aspect
of you know every aspect of your life if
it's properly oriented can become a
little tabernacle
a little a little revelation um
if it is properly oriented you know and
so so i think your intuition
is completely right you could say
relatively secular in the sense
of this kind of this kind of uh let's
say this idea that the narthex is a
is a buffer space but you can so you can
see that there's a sec
there's a movement towards the secular
in the sense of uh
where the sacred diminishes at least in
its appearance
but then that that pattern is there
everywhere it's there in your heart
right you could say that
you have secular aspects of you you know
like when you're putting your socks on
that's a sec that's a far more secular
activity than than if you know when
you're praying or
you know when you are you're uh you know
when you're hugging your child
or something like that but nonetheless
the idea
it would be that for a saint they could
find god in
in all the little aspects like they
could encounter
the divine spark even in the smallest
act or in the the you know in the
littlest thing
so yeah
so wyatt lawrence asked me how should i
understand theosis
is it to become god-like is it to become
a copy of god
in the orthodox tradition is theosos
understood it's something with a
reachable end or is it understood as an
eternal process to appreciate
work and so uh it's
theosis is is is participation in god
it's to become a god it's to become
a christian a little christ it's to be
transformed as much as that's possible
like that's what
maximus always says that he always uses
that phrase where it's like
to the extent that that's possible and
then he doesn't he doesn't totally say
what that means
uh and the idea
is especially in saint gregory of nisa
we find that
he he matters he shows it as a as a
dynamic
thing which is that it doesn't have
finitude you don't reach
you don't just reach uh theosis
in a static sense but that theosis
although you you do
reach a level where we that we call
theosis like we talk about the mother of
god ascending
you know that we say that she's achieved
theosis but we also
see it at least san gregoriza talks
about it as this this
constant kind of infinite ascent which
has no
end um and so
that's the best way the best way that i
can
explain it for someone who who hasn't
reached theosis
you can look at you can read the the
writings of the saints of those that
that are recognized to have reached high
spiritual states and
probably find a better a better example
of that
um so jason lindsay says hey jonathan in
the lord of spirits podcasts they bring
up the notion that the giants could be
transformed into israelites and vice
versa
um does this process extend to all
manner of monstrous and hybrid beings
for example
mermaids and centaurs i see hints of
this in saint christopher yes
and dog headed men and i'm wondering if
this is perhaps a solution to the
problem of hybridity
that horrifying and well beings like
mermaids and centaurs could somehow par
become part of the center in a way
that's not destructive thank you for
your insight
and so yes so the story of saint
christopher is the best story
to understand that because it shows you
saint christopher is like a narthex he
acts like a narthex he stands on the
border on the side of the river
and his function in the cosmic pattern
is
because he's on the side of the river he
can carry christ further out into
the darkness and so that is kind of the
role of the hybrid
and the role of the of the marginal
beings you know but we have margin we
have
these saints there's a there's a mermaid
saint in the
in the ancient church uh like i don't
know what that means exactly phenomenon
like in terms of like a scientific
understanding of what that is but
those exist you know and saint
christopher is uh
is part of that um so
so so yeah you know um
but you see like you see in the story of
saint anthony like he he encounters
hybrids
when he goes into the desert he
encounters the centaur
and he encounters uh satur and
those encounters really seem to be more
like encountering the monster in in the
more
in the negative sense of encountering a
passionate kind of ill-formed uh being
in his himself kind of but but in uh
this i don't know exactly what it is
that he encountered but that that's
that's the story of uh
he encountered a center or insider here
i am trying to be a modern
all the time he encountered the sadder
and he counted uh a centaur
um so michael mueller asked in saint
paul a dragon what role does he play in
christianity
and so i mean i don't know if he's a
dragon but he's definitely the left hand
like that's for sure in in so many ways
he's a shape-shifter
he's he's all of that stuff and so he's
he definitely understand the symbolism
of the full and of the marginal
uh the marginal as
uh being something like uh like there's
a mystery
in that role and uh and for sure saint
paul seems to want to play that role
at least in some parts of his writing
maybe not at all but at least in some
but i wouldn't go so far to say that
he's a dragon i might be pushing it a
little bit
um so dan diego de la vega asked what is
the symbolism of constantine's battle
of the milvian bridge the kiron the
shield is dream and division
of army's seas my kid loves
constantine's story so i want to tell it
in the right way without fudging the
meaning and so
the symbolism of constantine is the
symbolism of a change of world that's
what's going on there
and uh you know so he
he has he has a vision of of uh
of the cross he has a vision of the name
of christ
and in that vision he's able to cross
the waters that's why the battle happens
on a bridge
and if you read eusebius you'll see um
that he that he talks about it as uh
he talks about it as as this crossing of
the waters like the flood and all this
imagery of the
of the you know of the israelites
crossing the waters
and so that's what's going on there it's
a change of worlds that's what that's
what happens
and you can understand it like even like
crossing from
the old rome to the new rome from rome
to cut to constantinople from the pagan
city
to the christian city uh that's the
symbolism of the battle on the mauvin
bridge
and you can also understand it like if
you want to understand it
uh politically it's also the breakdown
of the the the tetrarchy and so
you know that there was
at the time of constantine there was
this idea of like the three emperors
and so you could see it expressed
in the story of constantine the the
notion that this was
seen also as a kind of breakdown and
the civil war that it caused there were
other civil wars
obviously it was it was a rough time but
that these civil wars that occurred
in the empire were let's say
brought together into one in the vision
of the cross and the vision of christ
and so it's also kind of reunification
of the empire
that's going on there as well as a
crossing of the river some people are
going to hate me for saying that but
that's that's that's the symbolism you
can see it is some people might just see
it as propaganda but it's using the
proper
it's using the proper imagery no matter
what
so dortea asks why do millennials hate
their lives is it because millennials
are born into the edge of time
any advice it is definitely that you
know and it's like
a lot of people have criticized me
recently for for being kind of
apocalyptic in the way i talk but
do you think your kids don't get that in
school like my kids now
my kids didn't go to school for the
whole time but since they go to school
like they're far more depressed and hate
their lives why because
all they're being told is how the world
is falling apart because of ecological
reason because of racism because of
all of these things and so the very
school system is giving them
a sense that they're basically the last
right they're gen z
they're the last generation that's how
it's being presented to them
so so so it's understandable that they
struggle
because you know they're being presented
with an apocalyptic narrative
on all sides so i don't know what to say
i feel bad for them
um i think for sure i think for sure
the symbolic world at least i've seen
in the younger people that it's and
they're the
this idea of this idea of understanding
so we have an opportunity right now and
it's a very interesting opportunity and
you can see that i'm trying to use that
opportunity as much as possible
which is that there's a trope in stories
of
the old forgotten world right this this
old these old legends that
we've forgotten and you know and and
that are these hidden gems that you have
to discover and
and they can kind of reinform the world
you know there's this ancient kingdom
which is lost this ancient civilization
which is lost right
the the secrets of atlantis the secrets
of of the egyptians all of this kind of
desire to rediscover this ancient lost
lore and world it's like
we're in a very interesting situation
right now because christianity itself is
that
and so you can actually present
christianity as
this ancient line of kings and lord of
the rings that has been lost and will be
reformed you know the sword
that will be reforged for the for for
the final battle or whatever that type
of trope
is one that we can do so like what we're
doing with richard
uh richard rowland the universal history
is exactly that
it's like saying there are all these
hidden secrets and mysteries
which they're not they're not secrets in
a negative sense it's just that people
have totally forgotten them
and everybody used to know these stories
everybody used to
know this universal history now it's
gone and so we can rediscover it
like excited children that are finding
you know
like that are that that are finding a
seek a hidden treasure or something and
so i would say that's my advice
that it's a it's actually an opportunity
to uh to help to help them rediscover
this stuff so
you know all right so drew mcmahon asked
brave new world seems to come to mind
every day
yeah is there a bookstore a movie that
you feel best described symbolizes
represents the times we are in
uh also did you see alex jones recently
say that the number one thing he's
certain is real
and most ominous conspiracy are human
animal hybrids
and so i mean it's not a conspiracy
they're they they're telling us that
they're doing it it's a conspiracy
it's like i i mean it was before alex
jones was right
and so now they're actually telling us
that they're doing it there have been
several articles
that have been published about you know
how they they put
uh human human genes for intelligence
and monkeys how they
you know they they're doing all these
weird hybrids and the fact and they're
saying that they destroyed the fetuses
but it's like if those articles are
coming out
publicly it means that there's a lot of
stuff that has been done
that was not that we were not told and
so and so i think he's right
um you know and so what is the the the
story movie that this best describes
i think that in terms of understanding
the kind of um
you've probably seen the meme i've
talked about it before you know that
meme where it's like
fahrenheit uh and then uh
brave new world in 1984 like as these
three circles and it says you are here
it's like that's pretty much it which is
odd to think that but
it's hard it's so hard to i could never
have thought that
1984 a brand new world could come
together into a dystopian reality but
it seems like it seems like it's
happening you know
so this kind of weird control of
information but also in a society
a kind of degenerate society of pleasure
um
and so yeah it's weird
um so so charles harold says at the end
of second samuel in chapter 24 king
david takes a census of israel and judah
this is considered a sin for which him
and his people are punished
why was this a bad thing for him to have
done when moses did a census of israel
during their exodus was because
david was the king while moses was a
judge
um i i talk about this
in in my video on 666 on the symbol zone
666 i think
that's the video where i talk about it
uh in that case in the case of david
the the problem there's something about
you're supposed to like
offer a sacrifice in in a kind of as a
compensation for the the uh
the census because there's a there's a
problem with accounting for everything
right i've talked about this before
there's there's a difficulty
accounting for everything brings about
the end of the world
because you need to leave a buffer on
the edge you need to leave the fringe
you need to leave
the corners of the field untouched and
so there's something
in this idea of of a census bringing
about a plague
which very much has to do with with
with our reality now you know uh
so you can think about it even just
biologically and so
think about people who who are trying to
let's say
this idea of like putting in check all
diseases right of like
accounting for all the diseases and and
and and
getting it all under control right and
so
and then what happens with that is that
the diseases
accumulate on the border let's say they
accumulate
in the in you think you've covered it
all but it actually brings about
like a flood so it's like the tower of
babel brings about
the the multiplicity of language you
know and the census
brings about a play brings about a
breakdown because you're trying to kind
of contain everything in a system
and then because you do that
the the the side effect of that is
actually
the breakdown it's actually the opposite
which happens um
the the idea of like uh antibiotics and
this
this this desire to kind of stop all
diseases
is a good example of that and it's gonna
bring about stronger and stronger
diseases and
gonna get wiped out by a real plague at
some point not this
little this this small uh
i i don't want to downplay it but it's
it's this is not the plague what we're
going through
there's nothing to do with uh with the
real plagues that happened
you know where you know the black death
or
or those types of plagues so those are
possible those can happen by the way
you know that can definitely happen um
all right ann herrera says what is
prayer what is happening when we pray
man you guys how can you ask a question
like that um
sorry anne what is prayer i mean so it
depends it
depends i mean prayer is talking to god
and so there are different aspects of
prayer there's there are aspects of
prayer which are meant
to worship and there are acts so that
means attending to the highest thing
right and putting it in its place so
it's like lifting up god you hear that
in churches all the time we lift up god
because we want to recognize the source
of reality and we want to all be
turned our whole being turned towards
this higher thing attending to the
highest thing
uh i say thing it's obviously god's not
a thing but attending to the highest
um that's one aspect then there's
another aspect which is
asking and so asking has more to do with
creating the question creating the space
creating the
the opening in which the divine will
manifest itself
uh you know in which god will answer so
you ask a question and then god answers
and so you have to you that's also how
reality works right there
i've talked about this several times
reality works with questions and answers
frames
and discourse uh you know potentiality
and
actuality coming to manifest the union
of the two
and so that's another aspect of uh of
prayer which is
we we we and then there's a third aspect
of prayer which is
let's say praying for each other it's
related to asking but
praying for each other is is more
complicated because it's not more
complicated but
it has to do with this idea of
recognizing each other
as being as being in this relationship
facing that which we worship and so
we pray for our brothers and sisters
and we gather them into us and they
gather they gather us into them in love
and in compassion
and then that is what forms the body
as we do it directed towards the
infinite and the source of everything
um so hopefully that's that's a good i
mean it's like that's a tough question
because it's a it's a big question but
hopefully that's a little hint uh that
can maybe help you
understand why we pray and and what what
the point is
all right so lynn holland says can you
talk about
how your experience of life has changed
since you adopted the orthodox frame
and begin to view life through a more of
a symbolic lens
what are some of the bigger shifts you
have experienced on a day-to-day basis
in terms of how reality reveals itself
to you um
i mean one is it is just a kind of
wonder
you know a sense of wonder and a sense
of excitement and a sense of being part
of a story
and uh that i would say is the biggest
thing and it's like i'm excited about
reality even though even even the darker
aspect like even as i watch even as i
watch kind of things break down and i
kind of see these
the symbolism of the end kind of
manifest itself
there's nonetheless a kind of excitement
in the sense that it's not a nihilism
it's like i i can
see that it's part of the story and i
can understand it so it's like it's a
way to deal with that too
causes less suffering even if you causes
less suffering when you understand that
the suffering you're going through is
it's part of the
it's part of the story um
and so i would say that's the biggest
thing um
and then of course for me it was a way
to unite a lot of the disparate elements
of my
experience you know my my intellectual
life
my spiritual life in terms of prayer in
terms of of
spiritual discipline and then my art
artwork
the you know the my work in art all of
that was able to come
together in orthodoxy
so andy crawford asks what do you think
of the enneagram thanks
i have to tell you that i have not
really studied the enneagram
very much just like i've not really
studied jung and a lot of people i think
don't believe me when i tell them that i
haven't studied jung
but i just haven't um so
sorry all right so bjorn olson says
hello jonathan i'm an organist and i
wonder if you have anything interesting
to say about the symbolism of the pipe
organ
an interesting thing of note is that the
organ is usually placed in the back of
the church but it's still
often beautifully made and almost
demands your attention ultimately its
role is to lead
the congregation in song well for sure
the organ
wind instruments in particular are very
powerful because they're
they're really they're very symbolic in
the sense that
they're very symbolic of how reality
works which is that the spirit
the air goes through a pipe and then
turns it into a pattern and so you have
a body like a periphery you know you
have a circle
right i can't do it in in 3d and then
you have the air which blows through
the middle of it and then the circle
vibrates
and then creates a sound and then when
all of these different
peripheries all these different rings
have air
have spirit which flows through them
then those sounds
come together into into a a pattern
into the music of the spheres you know
and so that's why
that's why i think the pipe organ ended
up being the main
the main musical instrument for for
catholicism in the you know in the kind
of in the
i think it probably started in the late
middle ages i'm not sure exactly when
but uh when they stop just using uh
voice
because the voice is that already right
voice is already something like that
right you you have vocal pipes
and you you project air through them and
then they vibrate
and they create a sound and so it's it's
just that it's a it's a
it's a related symbolism to just singing
itself
uh but it's just now happening in a in
an object
or through an object let's say um
so i both understand why the orthodox
church won't doesn't go there
because it's it's like kind of like a
garment of skin but i also
understand why the catholic church
adopted it and why it's such a powerful
image
of how reality can can manifest
pattern all right so garth
natwick asks i recently started looking
into paul tillich after learning about
him from john vervicky
when i understand it seems that paul
tillich's theology tends to be labeled
as radical theology
john vervicus also classified you as a
radical christian in your presentation
of christianity
you know paul tillich and you consider
yourself a radical christian to be
accurate
uh so i don't know a lot about i've read
a little bit of paul tillich but i don't
know enough about
about him and uh i would i know i heard
john talk about that in his discussion
with uh jordan peterson i'm curious
i'm curious to what he means like i'm
just like i hope he doesn't mean it in a
kind of funny way uh a kind of
fundamentalist way but i don't think
that's what he means i think he means
something else
uh so i maybe i'll ask john to tell me
what he means
um and so if he what he means by a
radical christian
is that i see christianity or the
christian revelation
as as a as the very metaphysics by which
i look at the world i would say
yeah i hope so like i hope that's what
i'm doing or i'm
trying to do that if that's what he
means then i'm like i'm on board with
that
uh but i'm not sure i i he i think
there was something so mischievous about
that conversation all around
between jordan and uh and john viveki
uh it was something man you guys know
that i
maybe i didn't announce it yet but i'm
supposed to have a discussion
in september between jordan
john and i in like the same discussion
and so i'm super nervous about that
because
their discussion was very intense it was
was
odd like just very jordan was being very
i don't know how to explain like from
almost a frantic or manic in
in his uh in in his approach to the
discussion so
anyway we'll see how that goes i'm a
little nervous about it let's let's see
so anonymous says hi jonathan do you
believe that simulation theory
represents a swell in the post-modern
desire to believe that the reality
we exist in within is inconsequential
while also acknowledging the existence
of a creator do you think it's a secular
mask on biblical stories in some way
thank you for all you do um i think it's
i think it's man i think simulation
theory
at least like the vulgar versions of it
you know i'm sure they're more subtle
versions of it but i think
the vulgar versions of it is basically
just a denial of
of understanding the symbolism it's like
a
it's like they can perceive people
perceive patterns and people
perceive places where patterns break
down uh
and so they see that we do that so it's
like we
also create patterned worlds
uh but they see that it's somewhat
artificial as not just a representation
of our reality lays itself out and so
they
they end up having to posit a kind of a
simulated world in which we live and i
always joke about that i think i
mentioned that before which is that
yeah we do live in a simulated world in
the sense that
there are different levels of simulation
or of representations and those are just
language languages
that's just how it works but what it's
pointing to these
different these different uh let's say
embodiments or systems right that
that manifests something aren't pointing
to some alien creature
millions of years ago who created a
simulation or whatever like it's
pointing to
the in the uh unfathomable
of reality it's pointing towards the
something which is beyond word the
mystery which is beyond
name you know the logos hiding in in
creation
and so the logos is a hidden invisible
thing and the the sim the destruct
the symbolic structures there they they
point to it
but they never get to it they always
they're always kind of pointing to it
uh you know it's this this invisible
mystery so
that's what i see i'm i i always find it
funny
when i hear people talk about that and
yes i do think it's it's almost
like uh it's almost like a secular
giving in to religion without wanting to
acknowledge that that's what they're
doing
um and so it's very odd
so marcus david says which gods are
behind the kobit lockdown
is it the canceled culture god the deaf
the edible devouring mother
ah man they're not very good gods that's
for sure
they're definitely yeah we're definitely
falling under
under very strange principalities like i
don't know
exactly how to name them but uh
it seems like the best way to understand
that is that
the world seems to be falling back under
the principalities that were there in
the time of uh
of enoch is what i in the time of the
book the
description the book of enoch you know
this these
these moves uh between
this kind of degeneracy and tyranny
uh is is very disturbing and very scary
and also the the whole technological
aspect of the lockdowns you know the
whole tracking
uh identification um you know police
state like i don't know if you guys saw
some of the videos that have been coming
out of australia right now
man it's like you feel like you're
watching a movie you're watching a movie
they've got police on the street going
door to door checking in on people
and they had two people die of kobit in
the entire country
two people died and now they have police
in the street
man i don't know it just seems it's all
out of whack and
in my my uh opinion
desire to account for everything doesn't
it doesn't it doesn't end well
so anders ralstad says what is the role
of scandinavian northern countries the
universal story
is it recommended to see oneself as an
actor in the universal story
uh i think so i think that i think so
i think that the way that at least i
see the scandinavian northern countries
has something to do with the symbolism
of the north itself it's a
it's almost like a wind like a kind of
a wild wind that comes down from the
north
uh and can be very dangerous unless it
embodies itself
and so it it uh and so it's not just the
scandinavians but like
all the even like the nomadic uh the
nomadic tribe that came down from the
north like the huns or the
or the mongolians coming from down from
the steps let's say into the world
it's like this wind that passes through
and is very destructive
and but then if it embodies itself then
it creates a very sturdy
civilization and so you can understand
it also that the middle ages are
basically
if you want to understand the middle
ages they're basically the conversion of
the the scandinavians and so
both on in the west you know the king of
england
the kings of england the kings of
normandy uh
you know and so the these strong
principalities
of the middle ages in the in the west
the whole
development of of the night and
the the joining of a kind of heroic
vision
and uh with the christian
desire to serve the weak like that's
really the joining of those two
together and you see the same in the
east because russia was also
russia is adjoining of the scandinavians
with the slavs and that's how
that's how that whole world came about
um
so that's the way that i see that the
the that's that's the way that i see the
participation of the
northern story and so we should bear we
should be very afraid of
of the northern people when they when
they move away from christianity
we already saw what that looks like uh
not so long ago and as we see it kind of
happen again
for now they're very for now it seems
like the scandinavian countries are
excessively kind of
how can i say this they're compensating
for what happened you know
let's say last century but it can flip
because an an excess of of one leads to
an excess of the other
and you can kind of get it you can feel
a little bit of that in the
in the air let's say
so g garcia says you said in a video
something like i used to be a christian
platonist
did i say that can you go into the
nuance between christian platonism and
having an incarnational view
of reality um i don't know did i say
that i don't think i said that you'd
have to find i don't think
i don't think i was ever a christian
platonist um
i mean i'm a christian platonist in the
sense that i think that
i i prefer plato to the kind of
materialism i think
i think that i'm closer to plato than i
am to
to maybe to aristotle um
and so and i think that saint maximus
has the best of plato in him
and so in that sense there's the value
there um
and so so yeah so i i think that i think
that
kind of say maximus's synthesis let's
say
is the best one right where he's taken
the best elements of
of uh of platonism in the sense of the
logi or these forms
but these forms only exist in their
incarnational reality
and so to me that is the best balance of
the
uh you know of christianity and
platonism
all right so walrus queen 14 says hi
jonathan would you say that there's a
hierarchy of physicality symbols come
from the unit of heaven and earth and
meaning
an earthly body when not the purest form
of a symbol contain actual physicality
for example i know you've said in the
past that you believe that the entire
earthly ministry of christ happened
physically
that christ had to physically exist for
his pattern to have
power how can one apply this logic to
the story of genesis
if we don't believe that genesis
narrative happened physically but rather
where the best means to describe them in
human terms
does that not weaken the symbolic power
of those patterns how can we be
how can we be so sure that these
patterns are as described in genesis
will physically manifest themselves now
if we can't say they physically
manifested themselves in creation
does this not make the genesis narrative
a lesser form of physicality than the
life of christ
i think you're just seeing it completely
in the wrong in the wrong
frame like i just think you're just
seeing it in the wrong in the wrong
uh can i say this with the wrong
with the wrong lens let's say and so
this physically happened
i'm not sure exactly what it is that you
that you're referring to i use the word
event i prefer the word event
than the word physically happen because
if you're me because the problem with
like physicality is that it's been so
corrupted by
scientific description that as soon as
someone kind of says that it
implies this kind of weird historical
neutral physicalist reality
and so i think that i think that
everything in scripture describes events
but they just do so in different ways
and they do it for different reasons
and i've talked about that before the
reason why genesis describes the world
the way it does is because it compresses
so much
into it that the categories it uses
are the best categories all brought
together they're categories of being
categories of existence categories of
meaning
uh so so for example like when you say
that
let's look at what you said like if you
say something like
the stories of genesis have
physically happened and so what exactly
does it mean
for the spirit of god to hover above the
waters
physically like what are what is that
what are we talking about
like what are we talking about if if
we're thinking of it in kind of these
immediate kind of materialist categories
it's like it's completely meaningless
the spirit of god hovered above the
waters like i i
i you have to understand it as
as these universal categories of meaning
which are brought into a story
that really happened and there's no
other way to describe it
than than the way that it's described
there but you can't get under it and
there's no point of trying to get under
it
and trying to kind of see what's there
and so
so i don't know so i don't really see
that big of a difference between
between when i say that the story in
genesis happened and the story of christ
happened
obviously they're described in different
ways there's more in the story of christ
we're talking
there's more um
there's more giving in to individuality
right there's more
there's more place for the person the
way that we kind of understand that
today there's more
flavor there's more spice and so but
that's also because christ is
incarnational and christ tries to gather
all of this into into god
i don't know how else to say it i i hope
i'm being
i hope i'm not confusing people the way
that i'm talking about it
um yeah
all right so el dorado says what is the
symbolism of kink and fetishes
uh i'm not going to read your whole your
whole question
uh and so what is the symbol of king and
fetishes i mean it has to do with the
fact that
that the capacity for humans to have
desires
is is uh is unlimited
and uh and it's also not only unlimited
but it's also
uh it's also imprisoning and so
the so one of the reasons let's say why
in the christian church
sexuality is tried is it there's an
attempt to bring sexuality into
marriage because it's a constraining of
sexuality
in a place where it can reach its
fullest
sorry its fullest realization like its
fullest totality
which is that there's an aspect of love
there's an aspect of pleasure
there's an aspect of of also continuing
the species
and it's and it's done in a way which
represents the relationship between god
and the soul
now the the difficulty with with uh with
fetishes is that
what happens with fetish is that
people's desires go into
an a queer direction in a strange
direction
and then fall on on strange things
and then rest there and become
obsessions they become
not just obsessions but they become to
at some point if you go too far in that
direction
you will not be able to find
satisfaction and reality in a normal
relationship with a woman which produces
a child
uh but you will be drawn out of that
into
the strangeness of uh of uh of of uh
of your kink of your fetish um and so
and
but if you look at the specific kinks
and fetishes like a lot of them
they manifest what they are they
manifest extremes whether it has to do
with
with using toys with using exterior
objects to participate
in your sexuality whether it has to do
with with uh
with with with reducing your attraction
to
certain parts of the body uh whether it
has to do with uh
with going towards violence whether it
has to do with like whatever it is
they're not arbitrary they're completely
meaningful but the meaning that they're
showing you
is this kind of breakdown of sexuality
into all its kind of weird possibilities
and the trap that that does like it can
trap you in in
in that desire um
so so yeah so i don't know so so i don't
know what to say
you know and so but but it's like you
have to understand that
that christianity understands that
marriage is like a cross
it's like a sacrifice that marriage is a
form of asceticism
to a certain extent it's a form of
constraining sexuality
so that it doesn't get out of control
and drag you down into itself
so so that's the way that that's the
best way to
to understand that hopefully that makes
sense to you guys
so jason jason schweitzer asked if
you've read lilith by jordan mcdonald
i thought the book was quite amazing and
feel like you might enjoy it so i'll
check it out i know i have not read
that book um artem
carnock says hey jonathan thanks a lot
for your work if you had a talk with a
new age type regarding reincarnation
what your line of argumentation against
it would be like
by reincarnation i mean this idea of
having different experiences in
different bodies in different contexts
and historical periods
the idea of soul mates and all that kind
of new age stuff it's all hogwash it's
all
bold it's all crazy it's like i mean
it's like
i don't know what to tell you it's like
that type of reincarnation thinking like
the idea that
like i was some other person in another
time and now i'm this person
uh it's it's vulgar like it's vulgar
even in terms of
people like let's say proper traditions
that have
like a vision of medium psychosis it's
like
it's a you know this this idea let's say
of passing through different bodies
uh that's not this kind of vulgar
version of reincarnation isn't even true
in buddhism
it isn't even trend business isn't even
true in
in hinduism it's like it's a it's a
weird modern materialistic way of seeing
the world so i really don't have a lot
of patience for it
for that kind of stuff i always wonder
like i remember i like i have a friend
that i love very much who's like a
modern buddhist you know like a kind of
secular buddhist i guess uh
and i remember asking him it's like okay
so you believe in reincarnation and i am
like what is it exactly that gets
reincarnated
like you believe in you believe in
let's say you believe that all
is buddha or that all is one or that all
is is and so it's like what is it that's
being reincarnated
and i don't think they really that that
type of person don't really have
an answer which is sufficient which is
which is sufficient metaphysically
so do you mean that like the discrete
these discrete souls
i don't know i i just it it just doesn't
it a lot of it
i don't i'm not a big fan of that stuff
sorry
um so norm grenade says hi jonathan are
sneezing and coughing fractal
relatives of exorcism that's a good
that's a good statement i kind of like
that
yeah i think that's something like that
but like uh let's say uh
a physical version of what exorcism is
you know this kind of casting out
of the bad let's say um
all right okay so how many questions do
i have there probably a lot i probably
shouldn't even look at how many
questions i have left
all right so doosan bobby bobby
sorry sorry i didn't pronounce your name
right there doosan
a douche yeah so what is the meaning of
the two sentences in the book of numbers
is there a symbolism in census figures
themselves
um i don't i don't
know what the the the i don't know like
i've talked about
the idea of taking a census before so
we'll have to look at it specifically i
don't think i remember
the context of that i have to admit that
the book of numbers
isn't my favorite book i should i should
have the patience to get through it and
i
have i've read it several times but uh
it's it's one of those things where it's
like i know genealogies have a lot in
them but they
really require quite a bit of attention
and and uh
capacity to attend to detail uh to
understand them
so brett says did jesus christ pass away
because he broke sacrilege laws when he
took the world sin upon his holy body
the ark of the covenant
or haven't been watching too many of
your videos um
i don't think i think i think i don't
think how you could get to that
that uh i don't think how you can get to
that conclusion by watching my videos i
hope you're not getting to that
conclusion so the idea is that christ
gave gave himself like christ died
uh on purpose like he knew that he was
going to die and he says
it right so it's like it's there in the
story christ says
i'm going to jerusalem i'm going to die
he knows and he does it
and so it's not it's not like something
that happened to him completely
yes it happened to him but he was fully
participant in what he did
and so it was it wasn't entering into
death
to kind of to fill up death with god
uh so that's what that's what he was
doing um
and in doing that yes he did become sin
take the sin
on himself in the sense that he went all
the way down and kind of emptied himself
in that manner but uh but it's not it's
not as simple as the idea that he broke
sacrilege laws
so kevin patterson says watching the
olympic soccer i notice each player
acting as a head to possess the massive
body of the ball
the players submit themselves as body
for their team's head then acting as a
single entity they go inside the
opposing team and turn them into
potential an
opening appears and they square the
circle goal
frame the ball uh the soccer field earth
is held suspended in space by every
player communing with rivals and
conforming to the soccer tradition if
sports can express the pattern of logos
should we all become athletes and so
i think your intuition about the sport
is right you know it's like that's r
with the way you describe it is very
much what sport is
uh and i think that there's definitely a
place for sport in understanding
kind of the symbolic pattern um you know
and even
saint paul uses the image of a of the
athlete as an image of
of of the spiritual journey but
there's it's a little limited in the
sense that
it views reality basically as
irreducible opposites and so it has a
function but it's not it doesn't show
the fullness of the
of the truth because it frames reality
as two
opposites that one has to conquer the
other kind of these two opposing
opposites that have to conquer each
other
um and so it's more like war is what is
what uh so
it's not like there isn't a symbolism of
war definitely um
and so it participates in the symbolism
of war
so jan peter yager says would
would you or do you use inspiration
regarding your icon carving if it comes
to you
in a dream or would you reject it since
it comes from an evil principalities
it is hard to discern um
i mean not for icon carving like i my
icon carving is really based in
tradition i don't
i wouldn't um
like i wouldn't base my icon carving on
a dream i think that
in the peripheral aspects of a icon
carving there is room there is
flexibility let's say
and so i can have sometimes uh i can
introduce idiosyncrasies into my
carvings uh but it usually ends up
being like i said peripheral to the the
main character the main image
almost always has to be something which
participates in tradition
unless it's an icon of something that's
never been done before you know or icons
that i can't find examples of
and then i'll usually it'll be more of a
meditative
practice where it's where it's like i
read the story or i look at the life of
the saint
and i and i and it's more of a it's more
of a kind of
meditative approach than giving in to
dreams i'm not a big fan of uh
giving authority to dreams to be honest
um i don't tend to do that in my life
sometimes i wake up and i can
interpret my dreams but i'm always
always very careful
not to make that a central aspect of my
life
so dionysus says after a recent
experience on a christian discord server
that focuses on debating orthodox
theology with muslims
it became quite clear to me that a lot
of theological discourse tends to become
the breeding ground for harmful aspects
of the soul
i believe that concentrating on
symbolism and the practical work of
developing the higher quality of the
soul is a much better idea
what do you think is the role of
theological discourse relation to
different levels of spiritual
development and how should it be engaged
with
especially at lower levels um
yeah i mean you've noticed that i'm not
a big fan of the debate
mode uh i think it has its usefulness
and i think it's also
it's also uh a function of
of different roles in the church and
different roles in christianity and
and i think that you know there are
saints that have been uh polemicist
you know all through the history of
christianity and so i'm i don't um
i don't think that there's anything
wrong with it uh in itself but i do
agree with you that i think it's a
dangerous
space for the passions and
uh and and i think i agree with you that
i've seen
in some of the debate space people who
give in that they don't shine in their
in their brightest light in those
moments
um but i don't think that it's
necessarily
that there's anything wrong with with uh
debating in itself
i think that i there's a weird thing
on the internet and uh and i don't i
mean i guess i
understand it i i guess i understand it
which is the idea that it's like
like a lot of the people that are
debating are catechumen or they're not
even orthodox or they're
not they're barely christian they just
converted or they converted
two months ago or um and there's
something about that which makes sense
which is almost like the guard dog right
it's like
you know it's almost like the the like
i've talked about this before where it's
like the prison guard
shares very much the same nature as the
prisoner and has to
because he's the limit he's the edge
between
the order of the prison and the chaos of
the criminal but they have something
here they have to have something in
common
and so and so i think that there's
something about that too which is it
like the new convert or the
not even yet converted has a kind of
guard dog mentality where
they want to like they want to define
the limit
and so they engage in this kind of this
kind of uh
almost warrior-like uh attitude where
they wanted like
they want to find the limit they want to
define it and they want to make sure
they're on this side
and that you know the bad guys and the
others are on the other side
and so i think it's almost like it's
probably like an inevitable aspect of
this process of of the church um
but like you said there are dangers to
it as well but there are also dangers
there are dangers in
in not doing it like there are dangers
in in not
engaging at least in some aspects of the
church in uh
in in debate and confrontation to what's
false and what's not true because
then you get then the church into the
church will seep in all of this
nonsense and all of this chaos and all
of this all of this kind of uh
you know all these bad ideas so you know
i
i understand it but you're not going to
see me do that it's just just not going
to happen it's not in my nature
um so high bishop so stephen bishop says
hi jonathan
can you talk about the symbolism of the
double-headed eagle especially as it
relates to empire
thank you and so i talk if you want to
read about that i talk a little bit
about that in
my articles on the orthodox art journal
on the symbolism of the left and the
right hand
and it has to do with something like
authority and power
it has to do with something like the two
keys of saint peter
of let's say the church and the state
you know you can understand it that way
the church has
spiritual authority without physical
power and
the state as temporal power physical
power
uh whose authority isn't in itself
has to come from the other side so you
can understand it as this
this motor of reality uh which is the
the notion of yeah spiritual authority
and temporal power
at least that's the way that i
understand that and those two are
joined in christ in different ways and
in his icon
you actually see this uh manifested in
the uh in the icon of christ himself as
the blessing hand as
as christ you know as christ blesses
he he manifests this kind of direct
authority
uh and then usually in his left hand
he'll have a book which is this indirect
uh this indirect or secondary aspect so
like you have direct language then you
have written language which is like the
law
or the you know the the this kind of
materialized
uh authority and so that's what that's
that's the relationship between
the spiritual and the temporal and the
relationship between the church and the
state let's say
in the kind of byzantine understanding
and then later in this idea of the holy
roman empire in general
because the two headed eagle ends up you
know finding itself in
not just in the byzantine empire but you
know in the austro-hungarian empire and
then then
in russia and all these other places so
all right so hayden este says hi
jonathan can you elaborate more on the
symbolism of
arks discussion identity and relation to
of this to the flood has made me think
about how it seems the identities of
people as individuals
are being washed away by modernity the
solution that immediately comes to mind
of course is an arc
but hey i do not fully understand the
symbolism of arcs in general
do they relate to crucibles or the
roboros
and b it seems to me that since the
issue of
is the erosion of individual identity
the solution would be an individual arc
does this make sense and if it does
how could one go about to building such
an arc for oneself and for others
thank you for everything you do i've
learned so much
from your work and it's changed my life
for the better well thank you hayden
um so you you can understand it you can
understand it
fractally is always always the best way
to understand it
uh the church itself is an arc you've
heard that probably before
uh and the ark isn't isn't always what
we think we tend to think of the ark at
least
now we're not talking about the ark of
the of the of the
of the covenant let's say although the
ark of the covenant has some of that too
uh but like i can say the arc of noah
the idea of creating the ark the ark in
that sense
it's a it's a microcosm so the arc the
arc
isn't just about containing that which
is pure people tend to think that
but it also has the animals in there
it's like it has it has
the bird it has the men and then it has
the animals in there
and it's also um it's also a techne it's
also
a it's a it's a garment it's a it's a
constructed
thing it's like a temple it it has an
aspect of it which is also
a kind of artificial thing um
and so the church has all that already
so that really
should be the ark but if you're thinking
about
let's say building an ark
so you could say that one of the things
that i'm doing is trying to build an arc
that's maybe a good way to understand
what i'm trying to do which is that i'm
trying to
i'm trying to create a way of speaking
about things that contains
both that contains the pattern
in a way that can be held together let's
say uh
and so so i think that that's one of the
things that that that i'm trying to do
uh there are there are arcs you can find
i've talked about how dante's
comedy i think is is a kind of arc um
because it it has all of that in it um
so i mean
my answer is the answer that i've been
uh that i tell to say all the time is
basically go to church that's the answer
sorry man um so josh says hello jonathan
first i want to say that
thank you for all the amazing work you
have been doing that has really impacted
my life and i feel like i'm revisiting a
language i've not gotten
to use use in some time
all right my question has possibly been
asked already all right let's see
what is the symbol of wisdom being
represented as a woman in the bible i
have some thoughts in terms of wisdom as
a vessel for the promise
it says of god but would love a broader
understanding
um
yes and so
why is wisdom represented as uh as a as
a woman and so
it's you have to understand it at least
in the the
the kind of the solomonic uh tradition
like in this solomonic text
that it has to do with wisdom has to do
with with a kind of incarnation it has
to do with
applicability and so you have
you have wisdom and you have let's say
you have understanding
and you have wisdom so you have a kind
of abstract theoretical understanding
and then you have wisdom which is the
applicability or the
the ink the the that's why wisdom is
always like advice
and wisdom is like do you know if you do
this this will happen if you do that
this will happen so wisdom incarnates an
abstract pattern
and so that's why wisdom so you can
understand
like in the in this the
in these solomonic texts you can under
it's like it's
understanding calling to wisdom and it
seem
seen as like a kind of sexual union and
so you have let's say the
the higher aspect and and this kind of
applied aspect and so that's why like in
the scripture
the wisdom is referred to as feminine
but in the tradition wisdom is referred
to as christ
so it's like christ is wisdom because
christ is incarnate
and so the way that it ends up being
solved in my opinion
the most appropriately is not in the
theology but it is in the art
that the image of the the the image of
christ sitting on the virgin's lap the
the throne of wisdom that it's called
that is
the true understanding of the solution
to wisdom which is the idea or the
totality of this
problem of the the masculine and
feminine in
in in this calling calling that we see
in scripture
and so you have the mother of god as the
frame
the mother of god as the seat as the as
the place in which
the divine logos enters and then
but she's also a throne so she she
creates the frame she
legitimizes to a certain extent
legitimizes
makes makes makes
makes uh earthly you know this divine
logos that comes into her
and so christ sitting on his mother
together to me that is the best image of
wisdom
like the best image of wisdom you know
if you want to totally understand it
um but it's the what's there in the old
testament it's totally appropriate
um and i think that it's taken it's
taken
in problematic areas we everybody who's
orthodox knows about
the kind of the problem of sociology
that has appeared in the 20th century
um and i think that it becomes
problematic
and and there's a reason why we we tend
to
always want to show the mother of god
with christ because
that's the proper way to perceive wisdom
is this
as this the actual incarnation
um which has a physical bodily aspect
and a seed aspect to it
at least that's my that's the best that
i can do with that but it's a it's a
tricky subject the whole wisdom thing
the whole sofia thing is tricky
because it's so controversial in the
church
right now um
all right so romer asked hi jonathan can
you share some thoughts on the
differences and similarities between the
symbolism of the hand the eye the foot
in terms of the right and left example
left irises
symbolism versus left-hand symbolism or
right-hand symbols versus right foot
symbolism
um so i i'm still thinking about that i
i keep telling you guys i'm promising
you're a very complete version
of left and right symbolism but i think
that that a good way to understand it
has to do with this crossing over
of the left and the right that we see
and so i think that when you see a text
it talks about just the left hand let's
say
then it's usually it then it's not
differentiated but sometimes
you'll get a sense that it's
differentiated
uh like for example in the image of the
transfiguration you really get that in
the image of the transfiguration because
you see
christ above with uh with elijah
and and moses and then you see
saint peter who is usually like
a head like a cross from from moses and
then
saint andrew who's like a cross from
elijah and so there's this crisscross
thing that happens
and and i think that that's what's
going on with the left hand and
like the relationship between the left
above and the left below let's say
um and so but i don't want to go into
that too much because every time i start
talking about that it
it becomes very complicated but you can
find you can find a few videos where
i where i try to explain it more fully
but i it's coming
i will i will definitely make try to
write something or make something which
is which
which brings it all together
so joe kelly o'neil what symbol would
you focus on first when beginning to
apply symbolism to your life
especially when trying to understand
your own story
um i mean you
it you should you should obviously focus
on the symbol of christ in
in the sense not of thinking that you're
christ but but as a
as the ideal or as the model because
christ is the symbol like christ is the
ultimate symbol like all symbolism
points and is resolved in in christ so
so you've already got it you've already
got the place to look it's it's
when you talk about other stuff it's
always to kind of help people understand
why this this story is not arbitrary the
story of christ
um all right so amy says
i hope i don't sound super woke here oh
boy
so what are you gonna say amy i'd love
to see you talk more about late
capitalism and neoliberalism's role in
pattern inversion
as i've seen you have a lot of knowledge
on the subject when
push another conversation for example
when speaking of male and female pattern
versions in movies i think there's a
huge part missing about capitalism in
which the same patterns are used because
they are proven to make
money therefore women just replace men
in roles instead of women
actually having their own movies i think
viewing that from a lens of women being
ignored because they're not guaranteed
to be profitable is a part of why we're
seeing this pattern inversion yeah
definitely that's for sure i'm just
using gender moves as an example but i'd
be interested
to to hear your perspective and if
possible we'd love to hear you speak
more on the topic
in the future i am not a big fan of of
capitalism neoliberalism
i'm just like i'm not a big fan of
socialism either i'm not a
i find i find uh
i find the modern situation problematic
and that's why i don't talk about
politics too much because i don't really
see an easy solution
within this kind of weird this weird uh
setup that we've got like this kind of
modern state you know
uh materialist culture and so to me
the the capitalism and and communism are
just two
two sides of the same evil coin which is
to believe
that to believe that that uh
to believe that realization comes from
material gain comes from material
comfort you know it just doesn't so you
know but
what you're saying but sometimes the
money thing or the
the commercial thing can be helpful uh
it can help you see certain types of
patterns because uh
let's say the market has its own
type of hierarchy of attention it can
mana it can help you understand the
hierarchy of attention
uh or sometimes like an inverse
hierarchy of attention too sometimes
uh because it's it's kind of like desire
let loose
and then the market trying to fill up
desire um
which is why it ends up in a way being
destructive you know because
it's like it's just whatever you want
you can just get whatever you want
uh but i agree that i think that that
that
in this kind of weird thing they're
doing in movies they're trying to
they're trying to to kind of use
something which they know
gets people's attention and then trying
to
trying to kind of play a strange trick
in it you know to to
to have us still pay attention
using the same trope and then replacing
the the main kind of
character of a very successful movie
that makes a lot of money
and then putting a a woman in that in
that role but
you probably heard people use the
expression
get woke go broke right and so there's
also reality to that which if you try to
push that too much
then people stop caring you know if it
becomes too explicit
then people stop caring um and that's
going to happen
it's already happened it would happen in
the last in many of the
of these these kind of uh movies where
they push that too far
all right so anjo terpstra says what is
the symbol significance
significance of the bush in the burning
bush what makes it different from a
burning tree does it relate to
hiddenness
or does it maybe we use symbolic threat
to other instances a thread to other
instances of bushes in the bible i think
it does
i think it does i think it's a thorn
bush
i and uh sangria nissa if i remember
correctly
says that it's a thorn bush and uh and
if it's a thorn bush then it really has
to do with the incarnation it has to do
with the idea of of filling up the
entire world with god's presence so it's
like the thorns are there
are the are the consequence of the fall
and so having a thorn bush
be a bush that burns and is not consumed
it really is kind of all of this fallen
reality which
which can none just contained in this
image and is
is being filled up with god um and so
so because it is this kind of total this
total material reality
that's why if you look at icons you'll
often see that the bush is
is the mother of god the bush is mary
and then christ is the fire that is
burning
and not consuming the bush and it has to
do with the
the virginity of of the mother of god
and a lot of the symbolism
so chandler turner says i know you won't
have much time when you read this
because you see that toward the end of
the the the questions do you
but i would appreciate some quick
remarks on joan of arc
i've learned more about her so recently
and found it rich with symbolic content
i bet it would make a great video i
think i mentioned her before uh you
might not have seen
that video but i i talk about joan of
arc almost like
us like saving the saving
the amazons it's like a christian
version of the amazons
where you have a a warrior virgin
uh who now serves
the king and so
that that would be something like the
saving of the amazons where
where the amazons are are brought into
the christian story
in a way that that can participate in uh
in the
in the christian narrative um
yeah and it also has to do
with something like the incapacity to
recognize that as well or to
the people in the story of joan of arc
were not capable of seeing this
exception
of understanding joan of arc as an
exception
but as an exception which was kind of
filled with god
and that's why they they basically uh
betrayed her
you know and uh and she was betrayed
because jonah in the story of joan of
arc you have all kinds of stuff going on
you've got cross-dressing
you've got uh this this this refusal to
to be uh married and you've got a
warrior
woman you've got all that going on but
but she
doesn't do it out of a desire to
change the structure of reality or to
take over or to invade
but she does it to serve god and serve
the king
and she does it in a in a vision and so
it's a
it could probably be a very powerful
way of understanding how some of the
stuff we're seeing it's kind of like a
saint christopher
symbolism how some of the stuff on the
edge can actually
flip and participate you know uh because
christ
i keep saying christianity is a non-dual
proposition so
some of the so it it's things like joan
of arc are going
to be part of the story you know they
just have to be
in their proper place and looking in the
proper direction so
um all right so enrico says hope you are
well
you have alluded at times that death of
christianity or decline
is in fact part of the christian story
do you mind expanding on that what is
pointing to it and describing that
or how you wouldn't understand it and
what is supposed to happen after this
period
i mean the the the proposition is simple
the proposition is that
the story of christ is being repeated at
different levels
and it's it's being repeated in
different uh
bodies that are growing you could say
and so
there are several ways of seeing it you
could probably see different
several versions of that but you could
almost understand it like christ
dies and then that death becomes the
seed
of this transformation and the the seed
which
the which becomes the the body of the of
of the of the church the church has a
body which joins the body together it's
resurrection of course
obviously too um and then the martyrs
die
and then that repeats that pattern and
creates converts rome right so the
martins martyrs die at the hand of rome
and they convert rome
and then there's another layer and that
layer is like a
bigger layer like a cosmic layer you
could say
um so you know yeah
all right so airy fisher says
what hi jonathan what would what would
be your main critique of raveki's option
what do you think of his critique of
theism
um i think i've i've i've said this very
many times i like i love john i think
he's he's a very sincere and
authentic person uh i think like my
difficulty
with the option is that is that it is
fragile
you could say it that way um
in the sense that it's idiosyncratic
and so because it's idiosyncratic it can
maybe help people on an individual level
but it it won't
it continues to participate in the
breakdown because it's like everybody
has their own little
practices and everybody has their
practices and they're kind of
idiosyncratic practices and those aren't
submitted to something uh and also the
problem
of new ageism in general which is that
if you're not part of a body
that has some authority then you end up
just doing the things you want to do and
you have
nothing to to to confront you with the
disciplines or the practices or the
transformations that you don't want to
that you don't want to that you want
you don't want to have um and so so
that would be it all right and so i see
in the chat someone actually gave 20
to say to say that i should take a water
and a stretching break and i
totally agree and i have enough energy
to to to continue
to go into the super chats but i'm going
to take two minutes and what i'm going
to do is i'm actually going to open the
window here
and then i'm going to get a glass of
water and i'll be back in like a minute
all right guys
i'll be right back
all right we're back that was quick i
don't know how it happened but
in several years it took several years
for this to actually manifest itself
but it seems like i found the secret
of infinite q a energy
at first i in the first times after like
uh
like after uh an
hour i was like exhausted now it's been
two hours and i still feel like i've got
i've got some uh some energy
all right and so all right so yeah so
i'm going to
go into the super chats and see
what's there so i hope everything is
okay
and uh and i'm sorry to lisa and brad
because when i make these q and a's last
forever i
basically and basically make them suffer
very much because it's very late for
lisa
um you know i i would totally forgive
you if you went to bed lisa
and and brad if you guys if you guys
checked out
and uh
all right okay so here we go okay
so all right here we go there's not
there's not too many so we should be
good
so the grub meister
for five uh australian i think what is
the symbolism of tickling
it has to do with the symbolism of uh
losing control right
you know we talk about i've talked about
how you know this tradition that christ
never laughed
it probably has to do with this idea
that christ never lost control of
himself
and so tickling is such a beautiful
image of that because it's basically
it's like
it's like i'm stro i stroke your skin
and you laugh
right it's like i i i i stroke your
edges
and that's what makes you makes you lose
control of your
of your consciousness and so it's a
pretty uh
yeah it's pretty simple i would say
um so the abc one two three four five
six
three nine nine for 50 usd says marsoen
times pajollian gangland i have no idea
what that
means abc but thank you for that very
generous
uh uh super chat all right numero
for 549 euros
how does a proper relationship to anger
look like practically in
christian terms what is the symbolism of
anger keep up the great work
and so anger
anger is anger can have a has its its
proper place and anger
usually has to do with the
reestablishing of sacred space you could
say
or the reestablishing of social space
and so you know to see christ
how christ uh turns the tables you know
of the the money changers is the
ultimate example of anger the ultimate
example of righteous anger
which is uh putting things back in their
place a rein
a purifying of the uh the chaos
of a space in order to make it proper
you know
um and so that's the that's the proper
that's the proper use of anger let's say
but it's it's tricky right where saint
paul says get angry but do not sin
uh it's tricky because because anger is
a passion
it's uh it's a dangerous game to play
like you really have to be a holy person
to be able to uh let's say manifest
holy anger
so sarah sanzig pretend usd says thanks
for your vids jonathan thank you
thanks to you i'm thinking of taking the
leap from lutheranism to greek orthodoxy
well
thank you thank you it's good to i'm
happy if i can play
a part in your story um
so david for taro for to be our brl i
don't know what that is
is not caring for your health as sin um
it can be
uh it depends it can it can be
if you do it out of uh out of pride
then it can definitely be a sin you know
and uh
people can definitely do that out of
pride
not take care of their health
you know this kind of desire to punish
yourself could
is can also be a kind of sin
if you're doing it you know out of pride
all of this stuff yeah but i i would say
that there are definitely
saints that did not take care of their
health but they did it
for the right reason i would say because
they were completely focused on
on god i mean there are some crazy
stories man you read the story of
of uh saying simeon the stylite man
there are some nutty stories
that i don't know if you've seen some of
these legends of saint simeon
you know the idea they found saint
simion you know standing
uh before he was on his pillar he was
just standing and uh
and he was he was so inattentive to his
body
that he had maggots like growing on him
like he had maggots
falling from wounds in his flesh and the
maggots would like turn to gold
things like that like crazy crazy stuff
uh
crazy stuff but uh take care of your
health you know
you're not you're not a monk you're not
a you're not a
an ascetic who stands on a pole when you
are maybe you know you'll be justified
that you not take care of y'all
so michael for five uh cid says
not withstanding whatever their effect
efficacy what is the symbolic nature of
mandatory for
forced coerced vaccinations
i mean it's it's it's it's a it's very
odd
it's all very odd
it it really has to do with a desire to
control everything or to account for
everything um and especially the desire
to have
everybody vaccinated like there's this
push to say
everybody has to get vaccinated uh and
it's like it's it's ideological right
it's not even medical anymore like why
would you have your little kids
vaccinated for covet
and so there's this like super this
really this push
uh and it and it really has to do with
with the desire to control but it also
has to do with a
kind of weird sacramentality you know
it's like
there's a quote i think it was it was
jacob russell who posted a quote by
uh chesterton in which he said
you know that the the secular state uh
is completely offended at the idea of
child baptism
um but is completely okay with uh
vaccinating all the children
you know because it it also ends up
being a way to show
that you participate in society and a
lot of it
a lot of it seems to be that right now
and so this kind of weird scapegoating
of the non-vaccinated
and uh and this this this desire for
to that this desire to kind of show that
everybody
who who doesn't get vaccinated is
somehow you know not a good citizen and
all that it's just very disturbing
all right so paradox for 199 usd asks
the same question or
what what's your opinion on the cobia 19
vaccine
so i mean i'm going to be talking about
like i know you guys are waiting for me
and i haven't done it yet i keep saying
i'm going to make a video on the mark of
the beast
and i'm going to deal with the
pronunciations of saint paisios on
the vaccines but i'm careful like i'm
careful
just because as soon as i announced i
was going to do that i received some
emails
from people that i trust who knew
payceos and new people who knew by seo
very well
uh and they they warned me to be a
little careful on that so
so i'm being careful but i will do it
i'm gonna talk about it i'm just going
to try to do it in a way that is uh
that is responsible and not you know
but i'm not going to compromise on what
i'm going to say that's for sure
all right
so grum meister for five australian what
is the symbolism of the jews
why did christians variously restrict
you socially or geographically during
the first millennium and medieval period
uh it's a it's a very difficult subject
obviously because it's very fraught and
it's very
um it's very
political you know and it has it's
difficult to talk about that without
people
getting into weird ideas or or falling
into certain
strange narratives um but a way
like i let me give you a little hint of
how i see this
it has to do with the fact that
out of all the religions that existed
at the convergent of the roman empire
the jews were the only ones that that
were
accepted to continue to exist let's say
and that created a dual relationship
between christians and jews which is
that
on the one hand christians preserved
judaism and on the other hand
the jews became the the
the remainder of an old world for the
christians
and in that imagery of the remainder and
the outsider
the only accepted outsider let's say
permitted outsider to coexist
then the jews also took on
all the the the negative aspects of that
like in terms of narrative and so they
became
marginal they became you know all that
um
and so yeah and so that's
that's that's how it works and it also
the jews themselves also wanted to
remain separate from christians and so
you ended up having
uh a a story of of something which
replaced something else and then
that thing that was replaced continued
to
to exist uh
and so it has it has it becomes very
complicated in terms of
what it what it manifests let's say in
terms of this remainder
and outsider who's not completely
outside right he's like the
he's kind of like the the
the this idea of the the two brothers
let's say that
are are together but are in conflict a
constant kind of low-key conflict
yeah and so that's as much as i'm going
to say about that
all right diego de souza for 10 brl i
don't know what the all these uh
these currencies are sorry um
is there an essential separation between
christian union and perennial school
perspectives on symbolism
and how it can affect our lives uh i
mean yeah
i think there's a there's definitely a
difference
and uh i mean i i think that jungian
let's start like there's a difference
between union and perennial school
symbolism because the jungian sees it as
a
first as a modality of the psyche
whereas the perennial school is probably
closer to the way that i talk about it
which is
that it's that it's actually the way
reality works like it's actually a
reality itself has a symbolic pattern
and it's not just
like the psyche or projections of the
psyche um
but the difference between christian and
perennial school
symbolism and my which is the reason why
i completely
embrace christian symbolism rather than
perennial symbolism is that i think
that the perennial symbolists they end
up
being uh having a kind of weird modern
abstraction in the way they do things
because they
they separate themselves even though
they don't some if you ask them they'll
say that's not what they're doing but
that's what they end up doing they
separate themselves from traditions kind
of stand above them and then
look at all the symbolism and then talk
about it you know
uh and i think that that's that's not
good i i
think it can be a little useful but i
think that
the wonderful thing about about christ
and christian symbolism is that it
contains
it's all there and so i i have
i live in the christian story and i'm a
disciple of christ
and once in a while you'll hear me point
to things that i've seen in other
areas or even in other religions or an
ancient myth or in fairy tales or
whatever and i'm fine to do that but i
don't i never
i really really avoid trying to speak as
if i'm kind of standing above everything
and uh
and interpreting it so so yeah so you'll
probably notice
a lot of the moves that i make have to
do with that a lot of the types of
things that i say and
the way that i speak about things
uh kimberly bulger says does your wife
study symbolism too curious about how
other women are connecting to the bible
thanks for your work jonathan
no my wife doesn't study symbolism she's
very little she's not that
she says sometimes that she's interested
in what i'm doing but
it's not it's not you know i love her
very much i love my wife
but but it's not her thing like she
she's she's a
she's very good for me because she is
very intuitive and very
like embodied and she actually has
uh more more what you would call
something like mystical visions like she
has
these types of experiences um and so
and so so we we don't totally
we don't meet in our theology let's say
uh but i love her very much
but uh it's not we yeah it's it's
interesting it's probably good for me to
to that it's like my wife is not my fan
like let's just say it that way
all right okay so andrew mensur for five
dollars says you mentioned
oriental versus eastern orthodoxy you
consider
misfitism heretical agree on uniting
ah man it's i i don't like
let's say as an orthodox christian i
have to say yes i think that it's
heretical
uh and agree on uniting i'm done i'm not
a priest i'm not a bishop i'll let them
deal with that i'll let the authorities
deal with that
i think for sure that i find great
interest
in in coptic christianity and ethiopian
christianity
in syrian christianity in in all the
ancient branches of christianity i
found a great resource but you know i
i don't i also don't i don't
agree i don't like just
trying to bowl over the differences and
to try to
to just to just pretend like the
scandals which happened in the church
didn't happen they did and we're where
we are
it's part of the story uh but
nonetheless that's that's uh
that's the story um
all right so maskowski for
maskoff she sorry for 10
10 p.m hey you hey
you ever heard of puddle analogy is the
theory that any idea of design we see
around us
is just the product of chance and we
force meaning on it
does that devalue the symbolic i mean
it's just yeah whatever you know
let's let's let's let's let's let's
break that down like maybe
once and for all like in terms of that
this idea of
any idea of design we see around us is
just the product of
chance and we force a meaning onto it
all right so let's break that down in
terms of this kind of atheistic way of
seeing things
and so you therefore you're also
a product of chance your capacity to see
design is also a product of chance
and so what are we even talking about
anymore
like what are we even talking about
anymore
like the processes that made the
patterns you see
in the world are the same processes
whether you even believe in god or not
that made you
and so if we
force a meaning on it where does this
capacity to force a meaning on something
come from
are we standing outside the world are we
like these aliens
standing outside the world forcing
meaning on reality
that it totally breaks down
like once you take the whole thing
seriously like once you
go to the end of materialism even it
breaks down
because you have to reconsider
consciousness as part of the system
you have to reconsider your experience
as part of the system
and people who can say that like
so so so so who is the person who's
perceiving the puddle
like where who are they and how do they
perceive the puddle
and then all of us other idiots are
those that perceive
the meaning in the world and are
imposing meaning and there are these
secret mystics
scientist mystics that are are able to
perceive the puddle
like i don't even know what they're
talking about anymore when we get there
it's like ah man yeah
there's there's such an extreme duality
in the way that there's like they can't
just ruin people's thinking
and not just ruined it but made people
blind like people are blind
to their own experience of the world and
it's like
yeah so yeah sorry
so matt for 499 usd says what is the
symbolism of simeon biles of the u.s
gymnastics for going the gold medal
for mental health seems like a sign of
the end of the world i don't know who
cares
oh man my capacity to pay attention is
uh you know
reaches its limit uh in terms of like
the little idiosyncratic stories of
olympic
uh gym gymnasts i'm sorry um
you know whatever sorry
all right so vidu zui for 5chf says what
does christ mean by the road
by the broadway and the narrow way when
most people really go to hell or is
there another interpretation to that
passage
oh man well most people go to hell uh
you have to you okay so you have to
understand it uh
you have to understand it uh like a
mountain is the best way to understand
it you have to understand it like
the world is made of a thread a golden
thread
right and the golden thread is that
which connects
god to reality
and so it's like so hidden in the
multiplicity
hidden in the the idiosyncrasy of the
world
is a golden thread now you can you can
understand the golden thread
like a thread or you can understand it
like a hidden pearl
you can understand it like a fish that
is hidden in the chaos that you can
fish out of the water it's all the kind
of same symbolism
and so the idea is that is that
most people get lost in the chaos get
lost in the distraction
of the world and they're not able to to
to find
and to walk on that ontological thread
which connects reality to god uh
and so it has way more to do with that
then then it has to do with a
description of
who is going to hell and who's not going
to hell
um so yeah
so that's my answer to that um all right
let's see so
i think we're done let's just see
let me reload this and see what happens
all right we got a few more all right
i'm totally have energy if you guys are
still willing to go i'll i keep going
i don't know where i get it from it i
used to
check out it's much faster all right
okay so not scotties for five usd says
what is the mirror
by which we see ourselves or the
wait
what is the sorry where's the mirror by
which we see ourselves or the mechanism
of self-reflection
i i don't totally understand that
question maybe it's because my mind is
turning into mulch right now
i mean i i kind of understand but i
don't totally understand it
uh charlie longoria for five usd
what does it mean that lot's wife turned
into a pillar of salt what is the
significance that it was salt that she
turned into
um
in that case in the case of lot uh
i think it has to do with something like
uh like it has to do something like the
ocean
like a weird like a crystallization of
the ocean
like uh it also has to do with something
like uh
like flavor or like spice i've talked
about spice before
as as a as a kind of something which is
added and so
something which is outside and added to
the world um
and so i think it has something to do
with that but i
this is speculation on my part i i feel
it's speculation
as i'm saying it so don't take that to
the bank as we say
uh so the abc one two three four five
six three nine nine four fifty usd again
my goodness but thank you
bodybuilding lifting what i don't know i
don't do lifting
i i i'm not i'm not super i'm not very
good at the whole exercise thing
which which i should probably solve very
soon because uh
like i'm get i'm like when i'm 46 now
and i've got that little belly that
won't go away so i need to
i keep telling myself i need to get to
it but i i just ah man i'm just
too much that's where i'm still a little
bit of a
a little bit of agnostic in the sense
that i struggle to
to to care about my health
the way that you asked if someone asked
me before you know my
wife gets so angry with me sometimes
because like i when if i get sick i just
act as if i'm not sick i try to act as
if i'm not sick all the time if
something's wrong with me i just try to
pretend that it's not there
i think that's also like a weird
masculine trait as well
and i also hate exercising because i
feel like i'm wasting my time
every time i'm exercising um
dude this guy needs to be blocked here
all right okay so samuel ramaleer for 10
brl says hi jonathan i've read
the hindu story of naresh narasimha that
really talks about the power of margin
and middle identities
you've been talking about can we read
our tradition with
read our traditions with our symbolism
um so i don't know i i don't think i
if i if i've read that story i don't
remember the name so i don't i don't
know so sorry
so sorry about that all right so i think
we're done guys
and i think with this some of the crazy
stuff going on in the chat
i think david prophet
says you skipped me where did i skip you
what's your question oh there i see it
yes i see your
question david let me let me answer it
uh sorry
david prophet 499 says can you speak on
the idea of initial instance and how it
relates to god and chaos so i don't even
know i don't know what you're talking
about what is initial instance
is it a scientific term
before other events i don't know what
that is sorry
what is it
sorry sorry man i i don't i don't
understand enough your question so i
so i'm not so i'm actually i'm gonna
skip it uh so i'm gonna go
guys thanks for your attention thanks
for
thanks for everybody and i really need
to
get rid of this guy this [ __ ] in the
chat
all right so thanks for everybody and uh
sorry to lisa and brad who are
up very very late um
and uh and so i will see you i will see
you next month everybody
and uh yeah thanks for everything and
hopefully all this whole problem of the
um
of the website can be solved and if it
if it doesn't get solved like you know
you
please write me right send me a message
and i'll try to make sure that this uh
that this gets uh this gets uh dealt
with all right everybody
so thanks for attention and bye bye
everybody